ladies and gentlemen you today in
laxenburg one of the best connected
countries in the world unfortunately
connectivity many other european
countries have a lot of catching up to
do in the prospect in rural areas in
jork he is from etf internet access the
straits waters an im power  user up to
have to many area said that only by the
state and central and often connectivity
in fact that of european house wood
still do not have access to high speed
broadband of the conference today's
zaman york calling for quite the future and
every part i will not  be any pride of
future except for adequate internet
connectivity in let me be clear
connectivity is not what you and i
know it's what our children and
grand slam titles agency debt gentian
or suitable user group for citizens and
businesses of today's generation dies
important to  access content services and
products the others are injured
important for businesses and public
bodies to develop and provide very
content serv  ices
for the next generation it's not just
important that will be weiter sei need
to enter the different working skills
and monsters and will be our society of
health systems quality of education and
the speed of development will
pantone connectivity and so will social
fashion and anyone  to be left behind like
simply canon digital divide type is
connectivity is keep it up woman economy
the creation of digital single market
contribute fair fleetwood pzpn create
many millions of jobs at constant
connectivity with beer we want full
unity for european businesses and small
to freeze p future  sex es on cloud
computing on big data authentication
building industry on chf manager
innovations depends on our capacity for
the blue injoy with the connectivity
these gentlemen oems beijing tour the
ans set for years ago the events and the
importance of the state of the art
internet connectivity  convinced that
today twenty twenty twenty twenty
because if the  s the built
infrastructure decreases again forward and
long-term
because we cannot afford to build
networks will biopsie love you live nina
decade the cost city title will but
happy power consumption of the economy
and society for twenty twenty keeps the
public consultation and in need for
speed and quality beyond venti if
the salt is up consultation show
some interesting trends need for future
improvement in connectivity features
accusation extend mobile connectivity and
enforcement built download speedster
but features in partykeller
upload speed internet connectivity is
clearly considered as a service iaas for
employment  fashion week and learning for
research and activities
the level of quality and speed will be full
4 future needs and last but not least
many responders syndicate public on
need to promote investment and take up
connectivity networks and services in
lion know beyond identified future
beatz read gentleman let  me be clear
w  ie du nord probst public initiative
place market players are offered to sign
blank 62 x up to the market place to
invest in the infrastructure of the public
support on me who market solutions
will.i.am 17 as in scenario with petri
label incentives and noble investment
and to use the public marinovic is
smart and efficient very good news ist
wer fallen ding tools to this entry
using them and we will do it
increasingly account or supporting
fine tuning auer regulatoren warm and
making of the best place for investing
in state of the art networks  and for
making the most creative ist innovative
satisfied users of services and
applications in built buses networks
read gentleman hear your call for
future vom ihr bright future - gigabit
society ist - mocsai society rely on
network swiss gigabyte potential
gigabyte potential 100 only have spent
the sources  parameters increasingly
important jazz latency and reliability of
the work default very much improved
when s p
increase  s the world to play with no
doubt about it this wore fix networks
s fiber is future pendele was gigabyte
speech true for mobile connectivity s
fiber is the competitor on the mobile
backhaul with wireless connectivity
services on the move and supporting the
universe high speed and high  quality on
twenty twenty four in the challenge such as
in providing seamless a flexible
connectivity support emi music peter
nowhere is it who many people at the
same time location image expect to
generate end users can be implemented
to high end security networks consists
of large number of  small cells to serve
the nearby users well enough set
networks will e on verra dynamics
transport solutions and connections camp
by ashley software controller and
flexible in love mobile backhaul to
support a huge pattern read gentleman
how shoot and connectivity set
gigabytes to be title need in sure  that
this conference the third and wild cherry
on experience and expectations p  rojects
and prospects
abu dhabi through here from you can t help
you in making supplied the future the
future on site often as a very peaceful deployment
conference screenings
from brussels zu laxenburg 1 nv years
attention